seit einigen wochen ist deutschland auf
dem stand eines entwicklungslandes
jedenfalls wenn man sich die
einsatzfähigkeit des deutschen
gesundheitssystems ansieht und das ist
nur sehr beschränkt einsatzfähig weil es
viel zu wenig schutz kleidung gibt die
konsequenz tausende pflegerinnen und
pfleger und ärzte innen und ärzte haben
sich bereits mit dem corona virus
infiziert und es werden noch tausende
dazu kommen schuld daran ist die
bundesregierung und im besonderen
bundesgesundheitsministeriums sparen
weil er die pandemie simpel und einfach
verharmlost und verschlafen hat er
wirklich cupid 19 mit einer grippe und
erklärte dass der krankheitsverlauf bei
corona aber milder sei unglaublich aber
diese wirklich törichte aussage von
verschwörungstheoretikern hat er
tatsächlich gemacht und das als der
zuständige fachminister das ist schlimm
doch es gibt positive nachrichten die
hoffnung machen klick zum science
fiction die spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's rechtlich kein bericht sondern 1
kommentar ein wheelock zu dem
desaströsen mangel an schutzkleidung und
masken in deutschland herzlich
willkommen ich bin ja wirklich kein
anhänger von verschwörungstheorien aber
als das robert koch institut in person
von vize-präsident lars schaade
verkündete dass schutzmasken keinen
schutz bieten würden da war ich doch
etwas perplex und wir fällen empfehlen
ebenfalls nicht die nutzung von
gesichtsmasken oder mund nasenschutz im
allgemeinen in der allgemeinen
öffentlichkeit und im alltagsleben und
als es noch hieß dass es keine
wissenschaftliche nachweise über den
schutz vor viren gäbe da bin ich dann
vom stuhl gefallen es gibt einfach keine
wissenschaftliche evidenz dass das
irgendeinen sinn hätte und habe gleich
zwei studien gefunden da hatten wir ja
darüber berichtet da fühlt man sich von
den experten und der politik schon ein
wenig verschaukelt und warum heißt es
dann plötzlich mund nasen schutz dient
dem schutz anderer vor eine infektion
also wenn jemand selber infiziert ist
dann ist es klar dass ein mund
nasenschutz dazu führt dass wenn man
hustet oder niest die tröpfchen nicht so
weit fliegen können
bildlich gesprochen und dann schützt man
dem gegenüber das ist sinnvoll und das
empfehlen wir seit anfang an und das
empfehlen wir natürlich auch weiter das
problem war und ist ja auch offenkundig
ein anderes wie es detlef lins vom wdr
in den tagesthemen kommentierte als
wollen
krankenhäusern rund um heinsberg schon
vor vielen wochen nach schutzkleidung
rief hatten die politisch
verantwortlichen in land und bund die
ruhe weg keine ausreichenden
lieferketten für kittel und masken und
vor allem keine vorstellung dass das
chaos bald überall regieren könnte die
politik und namentlich der
bundesgesundheitsministeriums sparen hat
zu spät und äußerst effektiv reagiert
und wenn er auf nachfrage des zdf
magazins frontal 21 antwortet die
bundesregierung hat frühzeitig gemeinsam
mit allen akteuren des gesundheitswesens
maßnahmen ergriffen um für ausreichende
schutzausrüstung zu sorgen entspricht
das schlicht und einfach nicht den
tatsachen
und wenn man dann den präsidenten des
robert-koch-instituts lothar wieler hört
der sich eine pandemie nicht vorstellen
konnte alle sind in einer krise die ein
ausmass hat dass ich mir selber nie
hätte vorstellen können dann verliert
man endgültig den glauben die
verantwortlichen scheinen sich noch
nicht einmal mit ihren eigenen analysen
zu beschäftigen bereits 2012 wurde in
einer risikoanalyse mit der bezeichnung
pandemie durch virus modi saß ein
szenario beschrieben dass der aktuellen
lage in gewisser weise ähnlich ist
damals hatten sich einige bundesämter
und das robert-koch-institut
zusammengesetzt und ein fiktives
szenario beschrieben
dort wird aufgeführt wie sich ein
neuartiger erreger von asien ausgehend
aus breit sind und zwar weltweit die
rede ist von einem zitat
außergewöhnlichen solchen geschehen auch
deutschland ist betroffen
so heißt es in der risikoanalyse von
2012 mehrere personen reisen nach
deutschland ein bevor den behörden die
erste offizielle warnung durch die whu
zugeht darunter sind zwei infizierte die
durch eine kombination aus einer großen
anzahl von kontaktpersonen und thronen
infektiosität stark zur initialen
verbreitung der infektion in deutschland
beitragen
obwohl die laut infektionsschutzgesetz
und pandemieplänen vorgesehenen
maßnahmen durch die behörden und das
gesundheitssystem schnell und effektiv
umgesetzt werden kann die rasche
verbreitung des virus aufgrund des
kurzen intervall zwischen zwei
infektionen nicht effektiv aufgehalten
werden in diesem achtung fiktiven
szenario geht es um einen erreger den
sich die fachleute also ausgedacht haben
und der auf basis des sars virus von
2003 basiert
in dem bericht des rk ii und der
bundesämter wird der höhepunkt der
ersten infektionswelle in deutschland
durch das virus modi saß nach 3
100 tagen erreicht 6 millionen menschen
in deutschland sind in diesem fiktiven
szenario erkrankt bei älteren menschen
über 65 jahren beträgt die sterberate 50
prozent die durchschnittliche sterberate
der anderen altersgruppen liegt bei zehn
prozent noch einmal achtung es handelt
sich um ein ausgedachtes szenario und
das über drei jahre anhält und am ende
sieben einhalb millionen menschen in
deutschland als todesopfer fordert und
zwar als direkte folge der
virusinfektion
das forschungsteam stellt in diesem
bericht fest dass die kapazitäten
unseres gesundheitssystem durch ein
solches szenario von millionen
infizierten menschen stark überschritten
wird menschen sterben weil die
krankenhäuser überlastet sind und kranke
menschen keine behandlung mehr bekommen
können
in der risikoanalyse wird die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür dass solch ein
ereignis auftritt als zitat bedingt
wahrscheinlich beschrieben statistisch
gesehen würde es einmal in einem
zeitraum von 100 bis 1000 jahren
auftreten und so geriet diese
risikoanalyse in vergessenheit und auch
gesundheitsminister jens spahn scheint
sie nicht gekannt zu haben oder sich
zumindest nicht informiert zu haben
noch ende januar verglichen mit 19 mit
einer normalen grippe auch das muss man
sich mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen
unser zuständiger fachminister glänzt
mit einer aussage die jeder grundlage
entbehrt und zwar ende januar also genau
zu dem zeitpunkt als der chefgeologe der
berliner charité
christian drosten bereits vor einer
pandemie warnte und noch dazu hieß es
die gefahr durch das corona virus bleibt
in deutschland gering und wir sind
wachsam wir sind aufmerksam wir sind gut
vorbereitet all diese aussagen waren zu
diesem zeitpunkt einfach nur eins falsch
und als dann unternehmen die mit
schutzausrüstung handeln dem
bundesgesundheitsminister vor einem
ausverkauf warnten kam nichts
und noch schlimmer das
bundesaußenministerium hat sogar mitte
und ende februar mehrere tonnen
medizinische schutzausrüstung na china
geliefert und auch dort findet man sich
und gibt statements ab die nichts mit
der realität zu tun haben
die bundesregierung trage grundsätzlich
dafür sorge dass spenden im humanitären
bereich keinen negativen einfluss auf
die versorgungssituation in deutschland
haben
das stimmt ja nun ganz offensichtlich
nicht das ist wirklich absolut tragisch
und unverzeihlich was sich die
verantwortlichen da auch weiterhin
leisten haben sie daraus gelernt nein
was schutzausrüstung in deutschland
angeht ist das immer noch ein absolutes
desaster und jetzt
man muss sich hier vorwerfen lassen mit
seinem leichtsinnigem verhalten leben
aufs spiel gesetzt zu haben
das ist wirklich wie in einem
entwicklungsland deutschland nett zu
hause schutzmasken weil unsere regierung
versagt hat uns zu schützen
es gibt einfach viel zu wenig ausrüstung
und da sich das robert koch institut
offenbar genötigt das märchen von den
schutzmasken zu erzählen die nicht
schützen
die wahrheit hat man sich offensichtlich
nicht getraut zu sagen und die wäre
folgende gewesen
die schutzmasken reichen noch nicht
einmal für das medizinische personal
bitte bevölkerung kauf denen keine weg
das wäre ehrlich und aufrichtig gewesen
und im gegenteil mit der verwurzelten
und aufrichtigen kommunikation hat das
robert koch institut hat es noch
schlimmer gemacht es ist einfach nicht
gut für einen ansonsten hoch
professionelles und effektives institut
in der kommunikation so herum zu
dilettieren ich kann nur dazu auffordern
solche kommunikations desaster in
zukunft zu unterlassen sagt der
bevölkerung was sie tun können und
müssen sprich nicht klebt das sind
irgendwelche masken jeder mundschutz ist
besser als keiner wir sind in einer
medizinischen katastrophe und unser
staat hat versäumt sich darauf
ordentlich vorzubereiten
das spielt jetzt aber erst mal keine
rolle die krise wird später juristisch
aufgearbeitet ihr müsst euch selber um
euch sorgen weil wir versagt haben das
wäre schon mal ein guter anfang
darauf kann man aufbauen aber siehst du
selbst um glaubhaft zu machen und erst
einmal abzuwarten dann eine 180 grad
wende hinzulegen man hätte ja schon
immer schutzmasken empfohlen das ist so
hoch qualifiziertem personal einfach
unwürdig und normal dass ansonsten einen
guten job macht ich habe mich lange mit
krisen kommunikation beschäftigt und
kann nur eines sagen das wichtigste in
der krise ist die absolut ehrliche und
aufrichtige kommunikation und an die
bundesregierung das muss effizienter
werden kann nicht sein dass wir uns
irgendwo auf dem transportweg die
schutzausrüstung abluchsen lassen
es hängen viele viele leben davon ab
denn wenn die ärzte und ärztin krank
werden und die pflegerinnen und pfleger
dann werden noch mehr menschen an der
seuche sterben weil sich nicht genügend
um sie kümmern können ich wünsche
niemanden dass er diese schuld auf sich
laden muss doch inzwischen gibt es nur
noch gute nachrichten von der
entwicklung der fallzahlen schon seit
dem 26
mehr sinken die täglich neuerkrankungen
an diesem tag hatten wir mit 7660
neuerkrankungen den bisherigen höhepunkt
seitdem sinken die zahlen und selbst
wenn die zweifel an der zahl der
deutschen intensivbetten zu treffen
dann dürften die zurzeit gemeldeten
intensivbetten für corona ist in knapp
14.000 ausreichen um die krise zu
bewältigen und wenn dann genügend
studierende pflegekräfte medizinisches
personal in rente
die lücken durch die erkrankten
schließen können dann schaffen wir es
dann sollten wir dem bund und den
ländern für den rechtzeitigen lockdown
danken aber nicht für die fehlende
schutzausrüstung die diesen lockdown mit
zwingend nötig gemacht hat und in der
medizin sollten wir den menschen die uns
dort unterstützen danken und das nicht
nur mit warmen worten und applaus
sondern mit einer kräftigen
gehaltserhöhung für alle die am unteren
ende der gehaltsskala stehen klicks um
gibt es jetzt übrigens auch als podcast
also dafür hier klicken hört also
unbedingt rein
der link ist eben hier draufklicken und
unten in der video beschreibung
ansonsten ist dann bleibt dran